there's an enlightening and sometimes
slightly painful exercise one can do by
oneself to learn a bit more about the
origins of how one feels and
behaves pick out something emotional
that you know you're not very good at
now and write it down on a sheet of
paper here are some examples staying
calm taking pride in yourself trusting
missing people who go away we often
observe these traits in our elves with a
mixture of puzzlement and embarrassment
why are we like this why can't we be
more normal what's up with us to find a
way to some answers continue to the
second part of the exercise insert the
above entries into the following
sentence how safe would it have been for
you to do this insert sentence in your
childhood I.E staying calm taking pride
in yourself Etc now try to reflect on
why it might have been unsafe to do or
feel a certain way in the past it didn't
feel safe to feel calm because maybe
someone was drinking heavily in the
house it didn't feel safe to take pride
in oneself because maybe someone was
obsessively jealous it didn't feel safe
to trust because someone was cruel or
unreliable it didn't feel safe to miss
people who were absent because maybe the
pain would have broken one's heart
notice that in all cases what in later
life becomes a problem starts off by
being a very clever protective strategy
we are more mysterious to ourselves than
we should be when we fail to see that
much of what we do that looks odd or
unusual in adult life is really a relic
of a protective strategy that made a lot
of sense in childhood the point of
waking up to the origins of a protective
strategy is that we can then learn to
see that it isn't necessary to hold on
to it any longer there is no reason to
fail at work in order to avoid the
Spectra of jealousy we can afford to
miss people when they go because they'll
be back and we can dare to feel and to
love we need not continue our loyalty to
our past protective strategies once we
understand the particular circumstances
that once made them so necessary and
that now no longer apply